We've all done the worse kinds of things just
just to stay alive, but we can still come back.
We're not too far gone. Hey youtubers it's Charlie and what the hell just happened on
walking dead
there are so many surprises during the
episode I'm and you might top five WTF
moments and then I'll do my review
so many things to talk about so let's
get started number five Meghan gets
bitten
so the minute that Walker started
crossing the river I was just sitting on
the edge my chair
but the minute the dirt starts to rustle
on the ground I just stopped breathing.
You just know the minute that
Walker's sinks his teeth into her it's
all over
Her death is like that first domino the
just knocks over all the other people that
get murdered during the episode.
Number 4 - The governor shoots Meghan in
the head after he finds out what
happened. This happen after the shit hit the
fan at the prison.
So the governor was already
full on crazy, but I never predicted he
would shoot her without even giving it a
second thought.
Just the look on Lilly's face while she was
watching that happen too. She was basically
seeing the Governor for the monster he
was.
Number 3 - The Prison dies. So the
biggest death in this prison
wasn't Herschel wasn't Meaghan, it was the
Prison itself. It was like a paradise,
like an eye in the Walker storm that was
surrounding them. But like all things
paradise cannot last, so they are cast out
of heaven.
If you consider that heaven. Number 2
the Governor's death.
So david Morrissey confirmed the
Governor is gone. He said he had to die
because he had just basically done the worst
thing you could possibly do. #1 he
killed Meghan
and then #2 he killed Herschel. There's no
coming back from that. But Robert Kirkman
said something really interesting. He
said
in the comics someone different kill the
governor it was an unknown character and
was a really satisfying. So on the show
they changed it.
So obviously Michonne runs him through and
then Lilly finishes the job.
Which I thought was totally appropriate. Early on kind of predicted that the
Governor's new family would turn on him
and they would either maybe try to kill
him or just abandon him. And of the two
I guessed that Terra would
have been the one to kill him given the
chance
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - The
Governor kills Herschel. So this was the
most dramatic death in the episode.
Herschel was kind of like
everyone's dad at the Prison. He was
the moral compass for that group.
So what's going to happen now that he's
gone? They're all kinda scattered to the wind.
and everyone is losing their shit. On
Talking Dead Kirkman actually said that
Herschel was supposed to die in the
second season but because he worked so
well as this moral compass for the group
they kept him on.
He just added this nice moral dynamic to
the show that was really interesting.
And now that he's gone it'll be really
interesting to see where these
characters turn to for moral guidance.
But let me know in the comments what are
your Top WTF moments from the episode?
And what do you think is going to happen
the group now they're all splintered?
So remember there was the group on the bus
and then there was the group that fled in
the woods. The show doesn't come back
till February 9th, but I'll be doing
bonus videos this month and in January so
be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get them.
Overall this is actually my new favorite
episode from Season 4so far.
I love the way that they killed Herschel
and the Governor because those characters
are so big and they've been around for so
long you have to kill them in a way that
feels satisfying and I feels like they
really accomplish that goal.
Herschel had a smile on his face I
thought that was really appropriate
for his character. He kind of felt like
he had taught Rick everything he could
teach him and Rick understood what he
needed to do.
The Governor on the other hand had hit
rock bottom. So david Morrissey said that
it was time to say goodbye. I totally
agree with that statement,
there's really no where you can go with
the character after he did the things
he did in this episode. After killing
Herschel.
That's when the most unforgivable things
you could do. You kill the moral center of
a group
I also though that the way Herschel died by
getting decapitated was a nice call back
to his speech
in the third episode. Where he said "you stick
your neck out". Now that we've had
8 episodes so far though and our
midseason finale, let me know in the
comments what is your favorite episode
from this season so far?
And how do you think they're going to top that whatever the season comes back in February?
Right now click here to get last week's
Walking Dead video and click here to get
my Top 5 most anticipated moments for
Sherlock Series 3
That's coming back in January. Thanks so
much for watching high fives will see
you guys tomorrow!